[Musique]
en cette période d'enfermement comedia
je vous propose d'ouvrir un peu les
portes et les fenêtres pour vous rendre
compte de l'actualité du golfe dans les
yvelines
on parlera de l'ouverture du camp
d'entraînement des futurs champions
français et de deux compétitions
sympathique le septième trophée des
chiens guides et le challenge de
l'amitié
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bâché avec la légende du golf français
jean garaialde bonjour genre bonjour
alors vous êtes ici aux galeries
nationales ou s'inaugure un camp
d'entraînement pour des jeunes de ces
champions il n'y avait pas ça du motel à
votre époque non pas du tout pas du tout
même quand j'ai commencé voilà
au pays basque parce que je suis une
masse basse il n'y aurait pas de partie
du tout c'était nous avions chacun au
bal de pactiser aubin et on vous tape et
bien sûr et on allait les relancer
on est en paix maintenant
bon c'est le progrès et heureusement
d'une part c'est bien mais ça ce sont
des installations comme ici là ce que
nous allons inaugurer ce matin c'est
unique 10 ans et unis on voit pas ça
dans tous les golfs
non même je sais pas si ça existe en
france je crois pas même dans tout les
mêmes dans tous les autres pays
espagnols qui sont très forts en gueule
et ce qu'ils ont plus de 2,2
d'installation que nous et non non non
pas du tout ils ont les espagnols ils
sont nombreux en france j 1
je pense que les fans en france donc
jouent plus souvent jusqu'en espagne
c'est possible mais ce qui à la base il
commence très jeune il commence qu'à des
cadets c'est lui télésat c'est ce que
vous avez fait tous les champions de
votre époque c'était c'était des gens
qui avaient commencé à porter les sacs
mais des audengeois et puis les
espagnols du nord de l'espagne
genre dans l'estéron terrasse santander
olazabal qui ici de saint-sébastien
aussi ils ont commencé aussi de cadets
mais les basques comme vous et ils ont
été les plus grands joueurs du français
pendant très longtemps
d'ailleurs on avait organisé il ya une
dizaine d'années comme ça amical
si on avait fait une sélection des
professionnels du pays basque contre une
sélection du reste de la france
match aller à paris match retour au pays
basque n'est gagné qu'est ce que vous
regardez évidemment c'est toujours golf
vous êtes vous allé taper des balles
tout à l'heure vous avez toujours un
swing merveilleux on peut dire votre âge
86 ans 86 ans donc ça maintient d'être
racontée cette course est conteur qu'est
ce qui a changé
quand vous regardez les champions
d'aujourd'hui par endroits votre époque
le matériel évidemment
on peut dire que tout a changé d'abord
il ya beaucoup plus de tournois il ya
pourquoi les étudiants ensuite tout le
matériel les balles vécu elle
les terrains sont beaucoup plus
soyez
j'ai rangé dans le gauche lui-même après
surtout en france ou en espagne
disons dans le continent a pris une
ampleur
c'est maintenant devenu soit presque
populaire c'est vrai c'est vrai est ce
que est ce que vous espérez qu'il ya un
nouveau jean garaialde qui l'a hébergé
en france j'espère y aura un meilleur
qu' il faut être ambitieux puis il faut
y croire mais quand on y croit
non non non jeunes il ya des jeunes qui
jouent bien en france i qui promettent
mais il faut concrétiser c'est ça c'est
lorsque vous jouez le circuit européen
1re catégorie 10 ans là vous êtes avec
des joueurs étrangers aussi c'est normal
et des bons joueurs donc il faut avoir
la volonté le courage de 2,2
de les battre il faut pas baisser les
bras eux aussi ils sont bons mais aussi
ils ont des jours où ça va pas conservés
dans cette cette année le français à
faire preuve de volonté est d'être
peut-être un esprit plus combatif
voilà comme vous l'avez été merci
infiniment
je vous en remerçie fier du nord jean
garaialde et puis et puis bonne
continuation et celle assez longtemps
avec nous merci
[Musique]
et
ce centre a donc été inauguré en
présence d'un grand nombre de
personnalités du golfe et sous le regard
de la présidente de la région valérie
pécresse le tout avec port de masques et
distanciation obligatoire écouter eric
bress signé le responsable de centre de
performance nous le présenter enfin on
attendait est très fier d'eux que ce
stade soit son enfants vers ça va
apporter beaucoup de qualités dans
l'entraînement coincé derrière que là on
est dans des conditions parfaites
parfaite au terme de d'exigences
techniques et stratégiques parfaite en
termes de l'unité de lieu et de gain de
temps c'est à dire que on a tous les
coups dans un périmètre assez proche
donc on peut vraiment travailler
rapidement tous les toutes les
situations dans le calme parce que cet
endroit il est
réservé aux sportifs de haut niveau on a
un outil qui qui qui crée de la
performance de par simplement son son
existence en fait pour moi c'est le
stade c'est la pierre angulaire du
dispositif mais il n'ya pas que ça il ya
l'hébergement donc un hébergement de
qualité avec qui peut accueillir 24
sportif et si staff et un plateau
performance dans lequel on retrouve les
outils nécessaires pour faire de la
préparation physique de qualité de la
prépa mentale dans des labos spécifiques
et du travail technique avec une analyse
cinématique de swing et cetera une
modélisation 3d de soins voilà ainsi que
une école c'est à dire qu'ici on a monté
déjà depuis un an une école collège
lycée privé hors contrat qui permet de
faire la scolarité sur place à nos
sportifs donc la journée type elle
commence à 7h30 l'entraînement en gros
c'est de 8h30 à 18h et puis après il ya
des événements encore des études un peu
après il ya un peu de récup
il ya le dîner le coucher c'est très
dense et c'est un enchaînement de
de suivi par des coachs donc un coach de
physique et un coach de match le coach
de putting coach de près parental il ya
et ce coach là aussi c'est à dire qu'il
a il suffit de venir s entraîner là
c'est un coach en soit ce fait ce stade
essonne caece danse ça n'arrête pas
[Musique]
ce centre prend place donc dans cet
ensemble du golf national c'est-à-dire
dans les yvelines
et si l'on en croit christophe muniesa
le directeur général de la fédération
française de golf
ce n'est pas un hasard il dit à michael
et demi d'euros christophe frésard on
vient de voir le stadium qui met
réinauguré ici au golf national
le golf dans les yvelines prend de
l'ampleur à on ressent on assez mascara
sur sur le visage en ce moment depuis le
confinement le déconfinement le golf a
pris de l'ampleur
oui alors dans les yvelines c'est un
véritable laboratoire puisque c'est le
département le plus golfique de france
vous avez plus de 30 golf dans les
yvelines et la région ile de france et
la région dans laquelle il ya tout
simplement le plus de golfeurs plus de
150000 golfeurs licenciés en ile de
france donc
il y avait une belle carte à jouer pour
cette discipline dans ce territoire et
le golf a répond d'ailleurs répondu
présent effectivement dès lors qu'on a
pu retourner sur les parcours dès la
première phase de déconfinement de le 11
mai il ya eu un véritable engouement
pour cette pratique qui était déjà assez
populaire et qui est en train de le
devenir encore plus
non le mesure sur le nombre de licenciés
et sur le nombre de pratiquants
occasionnels et on considère que le
nombre de licences hier dans le
territoire francilien sur l'année va
être au niveau de celui de ce qu'il
était en 2019
donc on va pour ainsi dire pas perdre de
joueurs réguliers et on est en train de
gagner des nouveaux joueurs de l'ordre
de 3 à 4 % sur le territoire francilien
s'est pas forcément équivalent au
systématique sur d'autres régions qui
peuvent être plus impactée par le
tourisme golfique
on pense notamment à la côte d'azur au
littoral atlantique mais en tout état de
cause
oui le golf a le vent en poupe dans
l'île de france et plus particulièrement
dans les yvelines et à proximité de
saint quentin en yvelines
merci beaucoup pressé liesa merci à vous
[Musique]
un projet qui n'aurait pas vu le jour
sans le soutien de région comme
l'expliquent valérie pécresse alors
valérie pécresse vous êtes présente à la
libération de ce centre d'entraînement
pour les futurs champions de gold sap ou
l'application du conseil régional dans
ce dans cette inauguration a dans ses
équipements absolument nous nous voulons
que l'île de france devienne une vraie
région du sport et nous prenons appui
sur la ryder cup sur les jeux olympiques
sur les championnats du monde pour
donner à voir des sports que les
franciliens connaissent peut-être un peu
moi le golf le golf qui commence à se
démocratiser ont fait beaucoup de golf
scolaire on essaye d'amener les jeunes à
découvrir ce sport qui est un sport bien
être un sport de plein air un sport
écologique aussi et donc et bien pour
doter la fédération française de golf
d'un centre d'entraînement pour le haut
niveau et bien la région s'est investie
elle s'y est investie parce que nous
souhaitons évidemment se faire émerger
une génération champions pour 2022 et
c'est vrai que ses installations au
fonds appartiennent à la région
absolument alors une corde nous sommes
arrivés
en 2016 nous avions un manque
d'infrastructures sportives parce que la
région a une population extrêmement
jeune
et donc on manquait d'infrastructures
sportives par rapport au reste de la
france
donc on ne sait puissamment investi là
dessus davantage d'infrastructures de
proximité et des infrastructures
évidemment pas seulement à paris mais
dans toute l'ile-de-france petite grande
couronne de façon à ce que l'on mette
tous le sport dans nos vies qu'on se
soit en amateur ou bien évidemment en
compétition ou en voiture alors c'est
vrai que c'était le sport
ce sont des valeurs évidemment
absolument vous avez raison de dire que
le sport véhicule des valeurs de
dépassement d'efforts véhicule aussi la
santé puisque le sport la pratique
sportive c'est de la prévention santé
ça permet aussi de mieux de mieux
vieillir ça permet aussi de mieux
grandir quand on est jeune donc sur tous
ces sujets là je pense qu'une région
équilibré c'est une région sportive et
le golf est évidemment est très présent
alors notamment dans l'île de france
notamment dans les yvelines qu'est-ce
que je crois que c'est l'arrêt
département dans lequel il ya le plus de
deux parcours et comme vous le disiez on
est en train de voir une sorte de gains
de changement de démocratisation de ce
sport oui parce que il ya le sport des
clubs privés
deux tiers des clubs en france sont des
clubs privés et puis à le sport des
clubs amateurs des sports des clubs
public qui lui est beaucoup plus
démocratique et c'est pour ça que nous
avons voulu dans ce dans ce très très
beau lieu du golf national à voir ce
centre d'entraînement qui sera
évidemment ouvert à tous alors il ya le
golf mais il y aura aussi le rugby il ya
les audiences au pire du monde il ya
aussi les jeux olympiques dans lequel
évidemment l'une de france sera très
présent oui et puis avec l'aco vide vous
avez bien compris que l'enjeu de refaire
venir le monde à paris de me donner à
voir à nouveau l'ile-de-france au reste
du monde de faire revenir les touristes
ça devient un enjeu d'intérêt national
l'enjeu économique important un ange
économique pour des centaines de
milliers d'emplois qui aujourd'hui
sont très inquiets pour leur avenir
merci beaucoup
[Musique]
allez on quitte le golf national pour
aller en pas très loin à isabela
c'est-à-dire à plaisir alors de sam gold
isabella plaisir dans les yvelines où se
déroule le septième trophée des chiens
guides organisé par vous stéphane que
nous mais oui tout à fait cher patrice
non seulement le patron du golf ta wii
il classe les gold absolument isabella
ses trois étoiles un gros gros gros 3
étoiles est pas loin
lemmy tout cas pourquoi ce cadre il faut
qu'il ajoute encore un peu de services
et d'équipements
c'est le septième septième édition a
commencé en 2017
oui d'où est venue l'idée pourquoi le
chien guide quoi très bonne question bas
d'échelle qui fait juste 59 ans que
j'aime les animaux
ouais et que ça fait trente ans que je
suis dans le golfe et un matin je me
suis regardé dans le miroir en disant
mais tu pourrais peut-être te rendre un
peu intelligent et avec ton canada
dresse organiser un des trophées de golf
il vient et hâtifs surtout que
j'apprécie la fusion de lettres et
l'animal puisqu'aujourd'hui c'est un
véritable tandem entre la personne
malvoyante
avob et son chien ou sa chienne alors
c'est un trophée donc qui a lieu
aujourd'hui à isabela comment l'idée
c'est quoi c'est de rapporter un peu
d'argent pour le bouhris donc vous avez
des frais
pour payer l'organisation le restaurant
le gold droit de jeu est bien évidemment
où je vais tout à l'heure me mettre en
quatre en huit ans 12
ça va être la vente aux enchères donc
j'ai la chance d'avoir énormément de
partenaires qui me suivent comme
troubles m comme krups comme garmin
comme flight golfe qui fait aussi des
vidéos de drones mais parce que on voit
qu'il ya beaucoup de cadeaux incroyable
il ya à peu près 15 mille euros de
cadeaux vous avez à peu près quinze
mille euros de cadeaux va y avoir une
vente aux enchères
oui vous allez être derrière le marteau
à presque 1
mais j'ai le bâton si ces bas celle ci
s'est passé bien vendu alors sachez que
le mot de la fin pour moi c'est que le
lean kha le labrador noir c'est mon
égérie et essai le la chienne de
dominique eh ben je vais aller les voir
super merci à vous merci patrice baï
[Musique]
frans
alors c'est le trophée des deschiens de
guide et justement je suis avec
dominique bonjour bonjour vous êtes mal
voyantes
voilà et vous êtes avec lingway wyeth
une chaîne de ghinzu puisque c'est une
dame 27 gildas c'est une école c'est une
jeune fille qui vient de l'école des
chiens guides de paris c'est ça alors on
va on va parler d'elle à 5 ans elle a 5
ans dire quel jeune encore
oui il voulait vous êtes vous l'avez
depuis quand bon ça fait trois ans que
nous sommes ensemble là sans que vous
êtes en voilà et alors est ce que vous
avez toujours eu un chien guide avec
vous est ce que c'est mon premier chien
guide
d'ailleurs ce que ça a changé votre vie
complètement parce que quand on est à la
can
on voit qu'il ya enfin notre cannes
cogne un obstacle mais on ne sait pas ce
que c'est tandis qu'avec link à tout est
fluide
elle est là elle va contourner
l'obstacle si jamais cela un gros
obstacle et elle doit trouver un plan b
si jamais elle ne le trouve pas elle se
couche et settat et c'est à moi de
demander de l'aide pour qu'on nous
apporte une solution c'est incroyable et
alors évidemment alors on parlera du
dressage peut être avec des gens qui
sont aussi des occasions voilà oui alors
il préférait mon éducation ne dresse pas
ce que dressage c'est un petit peu pour
lui mordant quand même assez sa race
c'est quoi c'est un labrador labrador
c'est pourquoi c'est plutôt les
labradors qui sont des expressions
maintenant ils ont labrador golden
retriever
oui berger blanc suisse berger allemand
qui revisite d'accord mais effective
marathon il ya beaucoup de labrador et
pourquoi pourquoi cesser leur caractère
l'école les les sélectionne parce que il
y en a dans une porte et qui ne sont pas
faits pour ça donc il le voit assez
rapidement et ceux qui ont des
prédispositions et bien pas dans le
cursus pour devenir chien guide
alors comment ça se passe votre vie avec
le guide
elle habite évidemment chez vous bien
sûr elle fait partie intégrante de la
famille elle est choyée et ça se voit
elle et elle m'accompagne dans tous mes
déplacements parce que je vais aussi à
la sorbonne
et elle elle m'accompagne matin sous le
bureau tranquille
nous prenons le métro nous revenons la
maison donc elle connaît très bien
l'arrêt du bus qu'il faut ah oui parce
que ce sont des chemins récurrents c'est
incroyable et quand on connaît pas et
que je dois le faire parfois tout seul
on répète une fois avec un éducateur et
après on se lançait elle a compris
voilà et est-ce que alors je ne sais pas
si c'est peut-être de
l'anthropomorphisme que je fais mais est
ce qu elle sait qu'elle travaille
oui fait très bien la différence oui
mais c'est quand elle joue elle sait
quand elle travaille c'est la même chose
dès qu'elle a le harnais ça y est on est
on est on donne dans le sérieux voilà
est-ce qu'elle sait par exemple que vous
êtes mal voyantes
oui alors le l'éducatrice m'a dit il
faut faire très attention parce que les
chiens le savent
soit on est mal voyance on est aveugle
totalisons une autre monde une autre
approche quoi selon qu'on et malvoyants
ou non-voyants elle je sais ce que la
celle et du katri ce qui m'avait dit ça
elle m'a dit l'heure elle sent bien que
vous y voyez quand même quelque chose d
donc des fois elle est un petit peu
rêveuse
voilà et alors évidemment il ya cette
période de travail puisque comme vous le
disiez fait la différence
et puis il ya les périodes de loisirs
oui d'ici là la sa vie elle a sa place
dans la maison
et puis on a de la chance d'habiter de à
côté du bois de vincennes
donc là c'est génial on la lâche el djou
allait elle redevient un chien normal
avec ses congénères etc et elle a besoin
de ça parce que quand on ça ça lui
demande une telle énergie de me
surveiller de faire attention
oui ce serait nouveau bureau un moment
donné on rentre voilà quoi c'est vrai
qu'elle a 5 ans voilà elle est pleine
d'énergie elle et primes de l'énergie je
voulais un chien énergique
je suis servi 1 1 alors voile et c'est
peut-être passé il ya des golfeurs qui
bus qui passe puisque c'est aussi c'est
une compétition de golf pour les pour le
sien guide vous dites que voilà ça fait
trois ans que vous êtes avec elle vous
imagineriez aujourd'hui une vie sont 100
jeunes on a pas du tout ne serait ce que
parce que outre son travail de chiens
guides
c'est vraiment ma compagne et même ma
famille beaucoup plus quand ils savent
que je pars pars avec link à leurs
assurés sont entièrement rassuré oui ça
change la vie quoi ça change la vie et
en plus mais ma famille me dit me tape
eu besoin nous je pars à l'aventuré avec
elle voilà c'est glinka et dominique
vous êtes 2 mais vous faites que nous
faut tout à fait merci beaucoup merci
vous colline cas merci molines cas merci
[Musique]
que les chiens guides aide les
non-voyants et malvoyants ça je le
savais ce que je ne savais pas c'est que
les chiens guides avaient aussi des
familles d'accueil et catherine vous
êtes familles d'accueil pour chien guide
racontez-nous ce que c'est qu'une
famille d'accueil en fait pour avoir un
chien guide qui soient formées et donner
un déficient visuel tout avant il ya
toute une chaîne de solidarité qui passe
en majeure partie par les familles
d'accueil
c'est à dire que nous on touche les
chiots vers l'âge de trois mois et demi
million les gardes avec nous pendant un
an et on leur fait découvrir toute la
vie de tous les jours de façon à ce
qu'ils soient aptes à ne pas être étonné
dans une nouvelle wii qui soit passion
voilà une situation pareille quelque
chose qui n'aurait jamais vu voilà donc
on partage tout avec eux c'est à dire
que moi j'ai un travail dont qui est
avec moi au travail il reste au bureau
lorsque je vais au théâtre au cinéma
voir un match partout ils m'accompagnent
partout dans les magasins bien sûr
d'accord qui prend grain il prend le
soin en commun mais vous vivez votre vie
quotidienne si je veux dire est ce que
vous êtes une professionnelle vous êtes
c'est moi racontez nous comment comment
ça se passe comment se passe une journée
alors quand ils arrivent tout petit
votre premier
notre premier objectif est de leur
apprendre la propreté et la marche aux
pieds
d'accord on propreté ça veut dire qu'il
faut qu'ils apprennent à faire dans le
caniveau et la marche aux pieds parce
que lui il faut qu'il faut que ça prenne
voilà pas être une grande distance a pas
tiré voilà éviter de faire des zigzags
devant nous parce que sinon ça nous fait
tomber la part dont moi j'ai un chien
oui quand je le promène ciselé en laisse
dans paris notamment
oui vous dans une ville et baril va
aller voir il va aller faire pipi vacins
sentir ceci sénat ça fait partie des
ducation nous on leur donne en tant que
famille d'accueil c'est qu'effectivement
ils soient concentrés sur nous
d'accord et puis après que sont les
après on passe une demi journée toutes
les trois semaines à l'école pour voir
presque le chien a pris pour voir si on
a des soucis sur dans certaines
situations
et là on commence à nous demander de
travailler les premiers apprentissages
qui va être par exemple la
reconnaissance des passages piétons donc
on leur apprend le terme les lignes et
en effet asseoir au passage piéton et
après de même qu'oddo nirvana c'est un
passage un pays dont ils savent pas ce
que c'est ils voient les 10 à 20 le but
du jeu c'est que déficients visuels
lorsqu'il sortira femme sinon au pied il
est le déficit annuel du rajout les
lignes droites et de chiens ira se
positionner devant les lignes et ça et
ça sera aux lignes pour son émission
visuel puisse traverser après la route
ils connaissent des mots henri
connaissent 50 me laisse un vide quand
ils arrivent en fin de parcours
ils sont ils reconnaissent la droite et
la gauche
donc ce qui est très pratique pour un
déficient visuel quand il veut se
déplacer
et sinon oui allez vale inco a win
conseil royaume moi je suis fasciné
parce qu'à 15 mois j'ai appris quelque
chose d'aussi gentil d'aussi 12 aussi
c'est incroyable il n'est pas du tout
quelqu'un sochi il est magnifique
débattue merci beaucoup 4e
[Musique]
c'est sur les greens du golf de saint
quentin en yvelines qui a eu lieu
vendredi 9 octobre
la troisième édition du challenge de
l'amitié créée en 2018 ce challenge met
aux prises dix associations dont 4
représente le territoire de saint
quentin d'un section golf de
montigny-le-bretonneux l'association
skies golf 2018
l'association sportive bluegreen de
saint quentin en yvelines et le golf
club de voisins-le-bretonneux le
regroupement de ces dix associations
donne une certaine force de frappe comme
l'expliqué philippe dubreuil de
président du golf club vit sinois
regroupe à peu près dans le ca fait dans
les 1400 golfeurs quand même hein si on
additionne l'ensemble des membres de ces
associations donc ça pèse quand même
quelques jours croit à ce jeu c'est
l'association sportive de montigny qui a
remporté ce deuxième tour devant le bouc
gris de saint quentin et sky gulf 2018
la formule est toujours identique 6
joueurs et deux remplaçants représente
chaque association et chaque équipe
d'autres comporter au moins une femme
chaque l'association donc présente une
équipe
cette équipe donc ces six titulaires
avec une dame minimum ça c'est une règle
effectivement importante
on a un double et quatre simples le
double en chapman et quatre simples en
qui jouent au scrabble ford plus de
remplaçants prochaine étape du challenge
de l'amitié au mois de mars au golf
national
[Musique]
merci de nous avoir suivi et à très vite
pour reparler de golf sur tv 78
[Musique]
m